good red dead redemption to be announced
at e3 the stars are lining up the Most
Wanted reveal since half life 3 is
developer Rockstar teasers two new games
ahead of III in June I'm Kate and this
is your pistols at dawn news update
grand theft auto 5 and red dead
redemption developer Rockstar Games is
hard at work on new games which will be
announced soon parent company take-two
interactive announced recently the
publisher did not provide any further
details on these games however take to
President Carl's slate off mentioned
during an earnings call that the company
is working on new IP to further
diversify its portfolio though it's not
known if one of rockstars new games is a
new IP CFO Lanie Goldstein also
mentioned that take-two is expecting a
75 25 revenue split between 2k games and
rockstar games for the current fiscal
year which runs until March 31st 2017
this would suggest that rock stars next
game may not come out during this fiscal
year additionally CEO Strauss Zelnick
said on the call that take-two has
announced its complete slate for the
current fiscal year and no rock star
titles are on it recently Zelnick tease
that the company had big plans for III
in April this year what was believed to
be the map for red dead redemption too
late suggesting that the game was
possibly a prequel to the 2010 original
do you think we're finally going to get
the sequel we've been hoping for what do
you want to see in the new IP let me
know in the comments or come and find me
on Twitter I'm at how not to draw thanks
for watching and for all your gaming and
entertainment news keep it gamespot